the jurogan experience how much time
before
there's regular travel back and forth to
mars
roughly
like a real civilization on mars
well i think it's going to take a while
to build a real civilization
the i the the real the threshold
that really matters is
for getting past the great filter uh is
do we have enough resources on mars such
that if the uh
if the spaceships from earth stopped
coming you can survive
yeah so that could only be just missing
one little thing you'd be like
you're on a long sea voyage and the only
thing you're missing is vitamin c
uh yeah it's lucky it's only a matter of
time
you know yeah and there's gonna be
curtains so
you gotta have uh all the things
necessary to sustain civilization on
mars
um and the reason that the shifts from
earth stopped coming could be
world war iii or it could be due to a
slow decline of civilization
so civilization here on earth could end
with a bang or a whimper
um or natural disasters yeah asteroid
impacts
in the bank category yeah but it could
also be like a whole series of things
like see like what killed the dinosaurs
well
it wasn't just one thing you know it was
like a whole bunch of things
happened in a row and and uh
you know um well they could have taken
any one of those things they had like
three things happen
and no dinosaurs which is kind of
amazing that crocodiles are still here
yeah those [ __ ] well they're
resilient crocodiles they
um they'll they'll live on decayed
meat they love rotten meat and so
in a any kind of disastrous situation
there's a lot of dead creatures and the
crocodiles love it
so um that's why they're around
crocodiles and bugs and mushrooms um and
shrews
true yeah this is why we're here yeah
exactly our great great great
great great grandparents were shrews
what a strange thing
so like yeah to come from so there's
hope there's hope for all you rodents
out there
yeah one day you can go to mars just
keep doing your homework
absolutely so so there'll be
the you say the great filter what did
you mean by that
um well so
there's something called like the fermi
paradox of like where are the aliens
yeah
so yeah where are the aliens
um and um
i think it was carl sagan that said like
uh if
there either are a lot of aliens or none
and the either they're equally
terrifying
um if there are a lot of aliens well
i mean the invasion ship slash
uh you know
bug infestation just you know like with
the starship trooper style well yeah i
mean
it's like as an alien civilization might
just view us as like a bug infestation
right you know it's like hey well if
that planet was fine now it's got a
bunch of bugs just go fumigate it you
know um
like would fumagate a house um that's
certainly possible
and then uh but if there are no aliens
well could it be that
all civilizations are just destroyed
before they become inter
inter stellar you know so
uh and i wanna be clear like
to the best of my knowledge i there is
no evidence for
alien life on earth that alien there's
no ev there's no evidence for alien life
there's no direct evidence for alien
life
no you know and if somebody says oh what
about this alien for
of you know uh sighting or whatever i'm
like
listen it's gotta be at least as good as
a 711 or atm cam
okay it's like if somebody's got at
least like an iphone one
level camera like something you know the
problem with that is it's just too easy
to fake things today too
yeah sure at least try hard in there
in fact are you familiar with uh
commander david fravor's
account of uh the tic tac ufo that he
encountered off of the
coast of san diego you know lex lex
friedman yeah
lex friedman interviewed him on his
podcast and i interviewed him as well
and if you ever
get a chance to listen to lex's uh
conversation with him it's really
excellent but this guy
is a naval fighter pilot and he talked
about this thing that they tracked on
radar that went from
more than 60 thousand feet above sea
level to one foot in less than a second
shaped like a tic tac no visible sign of
propulsion
uh blocked radar
actively jammed their tracking systems
and then went to their predetermined
point that they were supposed to uh that
the the fighter jet was supposed to
scramble to
went to it uh 30 miles away in
you know a couple seconds like they have
no idea how it did it they don't know
what it is
okay and these guys that were uh
working for the navy off the coast said
they had encountered them
several times they didn't know what they
were they didn't know what to do
whatever
photo or something they do they have
video of it uh okay
they have video of it they have um
there's do you ever see the new york
times article that came out in 2017
about this stuff
i don't know yeah there was a new york
times article in 2017 that was detailing
this and there's a couple of there's a a
couple other different
sightings that were very similar they
were trying to figure out what these
things were and why and
it was also in the covid relief package
that the cia was supposed to release
yeah these
politicians are trying to figure out
what all this [ __ ] is so they
try to get them to release all the
information they have within 180 days
honestly i think i would know if there
are aliens
i would hope so that's why i'm asking
you no i i i
i'll be jumping on that like be like you
should watch that conversation with lex
like here's the thing do you think that
they would want us to know
or do you think they would just be
observing and making sure we don't
blow ourselves up man they're real
civilizations they sure are subtle
[Laughter]
i mean if they wanted us to know
obviously they could just for sure you
know show up and
walk down main street you know okay i'm
an alien check me out you know
right uh he has my spaceship i just
landed in the middle of times square
i'll be like right
okay or hover over downtown l.a yeah
yeah we were like okay we believe you
yeah um so whatever they're they're
very subtle very subtle these aliens
how often do you think about it nine
zero zero
even though you're thinking about
interplanetary travel you don't really
think about aliens
no i mean if they show up i'm like great
okay now this is new information
but we
yeah what an interesting way of putting
it this is new information listen your
information like where are you guys up
till now
yeah um so
anyway uh listen i'm if if if i see some
evidence for aliens i'll be like i'll be
the first to be like
ah aliens you know right then you'll
investigate but until then you think
it's kind of a waste of time
yeah yeah it definitely seems like a
waste of time
if nothing's happened so far you think
about all the people that have been
researching
aliens for their whole life and they
have very little
to show for it well you know
there's other than cool stories yeah
um i mean we have archaeologists going
all over the world looking at things you
know
there's this people like if if we were
to find something like let's say like a
cube of titanium just like a
one inch cube of titanium let's see in
the middle of the
permit i'd be like aliens for sure
there's no way they could have made a
titanium back then
nope there's no way they that's hard
that's all one didn't even need a
computer like a computer would be like
hey wow computers they didn't have
computers back then so it must be aliens
but you but even just like some advanced
metallurgy
anything like anything like that
right nothing like that that we could
point to that we can't do
everything that we found
archaeologically is consistent with the
time
uh the technology they had at that time
archaeologically yeah
yeah yeah so you're just talking about
old stuff yeah yeah just throughout
history it's not like yeah
like the like aliens visitors would be
if something buried somewhere
i think um we haven't seen anything
so anyway i mean maybe there are aliens
but they're very subtle
if they are they're just very uh they're
being pretty shy
so as far as we can tell there's none
so nor are we seeing signals from any
other
solar system or anything like that so
um now and the thing is that
um on a galactic time scale even with
sub-light travel you could absolutely
colonize the whole galaxy even some of
the neighboring galaxies
um so if you gave if you said a million
years with car
with with and say there's no there's no
new physics
could you colonize the galaxy in a
million years absolutely the entire
galaxy
so you would start with mars build bases
on mars then use mars to jump off to all
these other planets
set up places there and over thousands
of years
yeah kind of like you know pop from one
solar system to the next
and yeah that it seems like that's
imperative like that has to happen if
the human civilization is going to
survive
because our planet is just we're too
subject to natural disasters and our own
folly and
if the species is going to survive we
kind of have to escape it's mostly about
the species i mean
there's been some real doozies of like
you know massive meteors and super
volcanoes and
the continents moved all over the place
and earth's been a snowball
and super hot it the if you read like
the
geological history of earth it's like
very long and complicated
um so and then there have been so many
extinction events
not like just a few um yeah i mean the
the permian extinction event that was a
real rough one
where it's like well over 90 percent of
all species
died out um and that doesn't tell the
whole story because
a huge chunk of the remaining species
were fungi
and um you know like sponges and stuff
like that you know
like if are you are you a sponge
okay you're probably doing okay they're
still around
are you a mushroom do you like being in
the dark and feasting on dead
dead dead dead plant and animal matter
okay
but if you're like a human you're
screwed catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience